(cheerful music)
- [Voiceover] Settlers of Catan
is one of the best-selling
board games of all time.
And nestled in the rolling
hills of Rossdorf, Germany,
on this picturesque street,
past the buzzer in building 43,
and standing in the back of the garden
is Klaus Teuber, the man
who made it all happen.
Settlers of Catan is a board
game for up to four players
where you collect resources to
build settlements and cities.
They're worth points.
First to ten wins.
(triumphant music)
And it all started like this.
- In the '90s and '80s, I
lead a dental laboratory.
Developing games was a
little bit a refuge for me.
- [Voiceover] His first
game was called Barbarossa.
- When I made Barbarossa,
I was in my early 30s.
I feel that this is a kind
of thing I like very much,
developing games, and it
could be in the future for me
a very, very good hobby.
- [Voiceover] He designed
a handful of other games,
and then made Catan.
(cheerful music)
Klaus had become
interested in Viking tales.
- Yes, and the story of
the Vikings inspired me.
I imagined how they reach Iceland.
They need wood, they need
houses and other things,
and so, out of this
imagination I developed Catan.
- [Voiceover] From design to
market, it was a family affair.
This is Benny Teuber.
He lives in Germany, and
he is Klaus's youngest son.
And this is Guido Teuber.
(clears throat)
He lives in San Francisco.
He is Klaus's eldest son.
- In my family, I am
one of the game testers,
along with my mom.
- Me, too.
We playtested the Settlers
of Catan quite often.
- We would all get together
at the dining room table
and would test and assess games.
- Sometimes he put a Mickey Mouse comic
next to my chair, so in
case the game was boring,
he knew that I would read it
instead of playing the game.
- My dad took that and
tweaked it, worked on it.
So this was sort of an
exciting moment for my dad.
- [Voiceover] In the Teuber family,
there's a bit of competition.
- My father would probably
say I'm the best player.
- No.
- Sorry, Dad, Benny is the best.
- Hmm.
- [Guido] There is a bit of a rivalry
between my dad and my brother.
(cards falling)
(laughing)
(light music)
- [Voiceover] Catan was
officially released in Germany
in 1994, and it was an immediate success.
- We had immediate success in Germany,
because we won Game of the Year.
- [Voiceover] Worldwide to date,
over 24 million copies have been sold.
- This game was born out of a story,
but it also creates stories.
- The beauty of Catan is that in the end,
you still have constructed something.
So, in a way, everybody wins.
- It was my wish to have
a very peaceful game,
with a lot of interaction
bringing people together.
For me, Catan was a success.
- [Voiceover] To all the
Catan fans out there,
here's some advice.
- Well, you always have
to follow your strategy,
but also you have to complain quite a bit,
even though you know you're winning,
you still have to say you're not.
- I love building cities as
early as possible in the game.
- Never build the longest
road at the beginning.
- [Voiceover] And there you have it.
(guitar music)